let's take another call here we go hi
theo this is
sarah uh calling from michigan
long short time listener person caller
thanks for calling sarah from michigan
uh
let's hear more and
i'm in my late 20s and deciding to be
celibate i've
had a lot of sexual relations in my 20s
and not really finding it very
fulfilling anymore
and wondering wait until i meet someone
that i really connect with and
have a decent relationship with
so i was hoping that you could
give me some advice regarding when to
tell someone
that i'm not going to be an easy
conquest when
is the best time that i tell someone
that well right now
uh you just told them and uh
but that's a good question when do you
tell somebody
that i think
you know i think you could let him know
at the end of the first date
in an appropriate way you can let him
know in the beginning i've asked
women out and they said from the
beginning if you're just looking for sex
or sexual interest
or touching or something like that or
body touching then
i'm not that person don't come around
here with that
you know i got a kid or i got you know a
couple cats or whatever i'm not trying
to put them through that
somebody didn't want to introduce me to
her cats until like the fifth date
i was like i don't give a [ __ ] i was
like i don't want to meet them even if
it's
200 dates i don't want to [ __ ] meet
them cats
you know some lady said well i don't
want you coming by the house you know
case [ __ ] mittens and bunny first of
all
you name the cat bonnie oh that's pretty
nuts
who would name a cat bunny and what he's
supposed to do easter he's just losing
his [ __ ] and doesn't know why
he thinks it's his fault that once a
year he [ __ ] just loses
loses his [ __ ] mind and starts
writing cadbury in his
in his litter box with his arm huh are
you [ __ ] why
does that cat on the internet that does
the computer
the office space one that the cat that
works at xerox or whatever what the [ __ ]
is going on
i don't ever want to meet your cats lady
and you can tell them that
i'll write them a damn note dude i'll
[ __ ] write a little note on the back
of a piece of salmon hey
nothing you can give him that
he ain't coming i ain't bringing i ain't
bringing you by the house
until you know she said you ain't
meeting my castle the fifth
date
and you know what i do if you ever do
bring me over there to meet them i'mma
hide milk in my shoes
and make them lose their [ __ ]
i'll [ __ ] hunt some four percent in
the bottom of each of my boots and just
just be that [ __ ] lean that leche
stepper
and have those little [ __ ]
losing their minds
so i don't want to even date that you
know i don't ain't being a cat stepdaddy
lady
so get your mind right
but anyway what are we talking about
sarah yeah celibacy it's uh
i mean you know what they say
this [ __ ] ain't for everybody that's
what they say usually
when people are celibate and they say
you know uh
you must respect this house and that's
actually i think part of a
under armour ad under armor ad but still
it's similar in that sense
yuma you know you must respect this va
jaus
you feel me this vajassel you know what
i'm saying
the drawbridge is up on this vajassel
and that's what you're saying and i
think you let a guy know that in the
beginning
just say if you're looking for if you're
not looking for something serious but
don't bait him with it the whole time
either
don't draw a little bit of you know
don't draw a little you know leave a
little pubic hairs on a napkin
you know don't don't leave a little
pubic hairs on this plate after he's
done eating so he
you know he goes to the bathroom after
dinner he comes back and then got some
freaking public hairs on the edge of his
plate
he's gonna be like what's it what don't
don't trick him like that
you know just tell him straight up and
um don't hold it over his head oh
maybe next time don't do all of that
[ __ ] you know don't do you know
it's not a bartering tool you know it's
a
but it is it's your item you know and
maybe he don't want to share the wiener
a lot of these ladies thinking oh i'm
keeping the kitty at the you know at the
corral
you know i'm keeping the carp at the
uh at the uh in the cauldron
but what if sometimes a man don't want
to share the weiner with you
ladies sometimes i ain't [ __ ] sharing
the wiener i'll tell you look weiner is
out
you know uh out of order i'll hang a
dang sign
i'll tie a little you know i'll put a
little i'll tie a little mess i'll
shave a message into my public area
uh gone fishing that's what i'll write
because sometimes your manning the
wiener's not always available
don't act like it's always red it's
always out there for you
i think everybody could say look it's no
dick august you know what i'm saying
that's what i'm doing ladies who's ready
for no dick
august these ladies thinking they keep
getting this wiener whenever they want
think again walking in a wiener
wonderland
no you're not you better
moon walk your ass on out of here
because you he's lost he's having a damn
lunar eclipse if you think he's getting
this wiener anytime any day
this ain't the 7-eleven a dick boo-boo
okay
this this this dick got limited hours
uh okay this the chase bank of deck
and you better this is only during
certain hours and
also i'm only working some time with
private clients
so that's what i'm saying this weiner
ain't available forever what what are we
talking about
but if you're trying to be celibate look
i think you tell them up top what do you
think nick
yeah i agree uh that's a good way to
weed them out
yeah good evening good afternoon and
other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah